conspiracy theories are just theories
about what could be a real conspiracy
and some of them are true a lot of them
are true so we should just stop treating
it in a negative way and and instead
think of like the lab leak hypothesis as
legitimate just in case the moment you
start censoring speech people
automatically think why am I not being
allowed to hear this I want to see this
I want to read it for myself Epstein
died and there were conspiracy theories
about that he was killed I thought nah
that's probably not the case and then
somebody wrote me emailed me from that
prison he said I used to work at that
prison and nothing works there it's a
dump I thought okay so this is the
conspiracy principle don't attribute to
malice who can be explained by
incompetence or chance so I'm back to
thinking he probably just killed himself
it's rational to believe conspiracy
theories because enough of them are true
it pays to error on the side of caution
just in case as they say just because
you're paranoid doesn't mean they're not
after you sometimes they are after you
right so when people say you know what I
don't really trust the US government I
don't
I don't trust the CIA the FBI I say I
understand there's good reasons why you
shouldn't
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People are brilliant and returning guest
today is a skeptic in Chief and author
of many many books including his latest
one which is called conspiracy why the
rational believe their rational Michael
Sherman welcome back to trigonometry
gentlemen it's nice to be back am I your
returning Champion you absolutely are
but for those people who didn't catch
the first interview just tell everybody
remind everybody who are you uh what do
you do what's been your journey through
life sure thank you let me uh introduce
my day job which is publishing this
magazine skeptic magazine we take on
just kind of boring non-controversial
subjects
race uh trans and abortion or the last
three issues of this year the average
trigonometry episode
okay there my friend that's right no you
guys are you guys are my inspiration for
doing this well I mean we've been in
business 30 years
um publishing started in 1992. mostly we
we focused on um science and
pseudoscience and the Paranormal to
Supernatural conspiracy theories aliens
UFOs Bigfoot you know astrology psychics
talking to the dead and so on but you
can only debunk those things so uh many
times before it gets redundant so we you
know kind of branching out into more
controversial subjects like the ones I
just introduced the next issue comes out
next week is on nationalism and then
next year we're doing stuff on Money
Matters economics you know crypto all
that stuff also mental health you know
there's recent studies showing that uh
you know like psycho psychiatric
medications appear to do very little for
things like depression maybe nothing uh
and so on so what's the you know status
of that you know so those kinds of
subjects that I think have more Global
and uh you know large larger cultural
implications so that's my day job then I
write books you know there's conspiracy
is my 15th book and because I enjoy
writing and and then uh and then I talk
to people like you
well Michael it's good to have you back
on the show and quite timely as well
because I think it's fair to say that
whatever your view of conspiracy or
conspiracy theories or whatever it is
we've never had more of them around
we've never had more of them in our
faces and do you think that's because
we've become more conspiratory minded or
we just have way more access to
information now
uh the latter there's there's just as
many conspiracy theories a hundred years
ago as there are now it's just that they
they diffuse through culture much more
quickly now because of social media so
if you look at uh like there's data
collected about uh letters to the New
York Times in the like 1890s to the
1970s and you can see there's plenty of
conspiracy theories even you know a
century ago about what the Mormons are
doing or the Catholics are doing or the
Jews of course always
um
you know and the influence on American
elections or the first world war was
just Rife with conspiracy theories you
know why did this start you know I have
a whole chapter on this in in conspiracy
on the the assassination of Franz
Ferdinand that that started the first
world war that was a conspiracy but then
there were layers and layers of
conspiracy theories some true some not
on top of that so that's not new you
know you can go all the way back to the
burning of Rome uh you know with Nero
being accused of letting it happen on
purpose or making it happen on purpose
you know so wherever there's power where
somebody has a lot of power and money
and influence and other people don't
then the people that don't are very
suspicious of the people that do have
power and for good reason really this is
what I call constructive conspiracism a
lot of times when people get in power
they get corrupt believe it or not
like like sand bankman freed you know
what happens this guy seemed like the
you know the nerdiest nicest guy in the
world you know we're gonna change the
world and effective altruism and
long-termism and oh my God this is going
to change Humanity then all of a sudden
he's arrested for fraud okay so
something happens you know when you get
into power so people see that and
reasonably think you know what I'm not
sure I trust authorities agencies
corporations people that are
billionaires I don't know if I trust
them and that's not irrational
um Michael one of the things I was
curious to hear your take on is uh We've
obviously lived through a time when
there's been a lot of fear
uh there's been a lot of power being
aggregated into the hands of public
officials and politicians and so on and
they've been wielding that power you may
agree or disagree with them doing it but
they have been uh people's lives were
changed in many cases irrevocably by the
pandemic and the response to it
um have we seen uh a rise in
constructive conspiracism or
unconstructive conspiracism during these
last three years have you is there
anything you've noticed during this time
uh well of course so you trigger you
touched on a couple things that are
triggered we'll say uh of causes of
conspiracism which is any thought any
time there's a major upheaval social or
or political or economic or whatever and
we got all of it with the pandemic uh I
mean you have political up you know up
upheavals and economic recessions and
and so on and also you know governments
just printing money and handing it out
uh I mean there's just there's a lot
going on there uncertainty nobody knows
you know to give to give some slack to
uh Anthony fauci and the CDC and other
health agencies around the world nobody
knew in the spring of 2020 exactly what
was going to happen What would the death
rate be of the SARS Kobe 2 virus and
covid-19 disease of it it you know could
have been like Ebola it could have been
worse and I'm fond of reminding people
Aids HIV was a hundred percent fatal
until the drug cocktails in the late 90s
100 right so you know we don't know
could be like that could be like Ebola
it could be like the common flu just
nobody knew so under uncertainty
um you know public officials are going
to err on the side of caution the
precautionary principle just in case so
it's a signal detection problem if I
miss it if I do a false positive I think
the information indicates that nothing
to worry about let's just continue on
business as usual what if it turns out
it's a it's a catastrophic plague then
that's on you you know millions and
millions and you know tens of millions
of people die wow as opposed to well
let's lock down and just in case and
turns out it wasn't that bad well you
know the long-term consequences we're
seeing now you know education levels
have been hit hard on kids and you know
the economy is you know in in the toilet
for a while anyway with the recession
inflation and so on that may be the
long-term consequences
but there's also excess deaths we have
excess deaths in this country at the
moment as well and I think your argument
it should be a little bit more
sufficient sophisticated that because I
agree with you in Spring 2020 we had no
idea and at that time Francis myself
everybody I knew frankly supported the
lockdown but there were other
opportunities later when we knew more
about the virus which is where people I
think are asking legitimate questions
yeah for sure I mean I think I think it
was clear maybe say
mid-2021 summer of 2021 when the
lockdowns were probably not necessary
you know the obsessive masking and
social distancing was probably a little
over the top I think that seems clear
now in hindsight maybe not at 2021 but I
mean it seems clear to some of us I'm
not gonna lie
yeah so okay fair enough uh so but you
know politicians again you're the mayor
of the Town you're the governor of the
state you're the president of the
country or whatever and you know they
stick a microphone in your face and go
all right what should we do you know and
and again your job is to you know
minimize harm in the short run right
maybe you know 10 years from now it's
going to look like this was a big
mistake but what do you care most people
in power are only in power for a few
years so they're going to err on the
other side I think that's a problem I
think you know the long-term thinking
and planning is probably better once we
know anyway so I I I'm leaning toward
you on that also the lab League
hypothesis to me has always been a
viable conspiracy theory here uh here in
my book I I try to debunk the idea that
a conspiracy theory should be a
pejorative it's not conspiracy theories
are just theories about what could be a
real conspiracy and some of them are
true a lot of them are true so we should
just stop treating it in a negative way
and and instead think of like the lab
leak hypothesis as legitimate just in
case because now it looks like at least
50 probability that uh that the SARS
Kobe 2 was leaked out of a lab versus
the zoonomic hypothesis
of course the problem is Michael we've
just been talking about covid and the
entire situation has been exacerbated by
big tax actions where they censor people
and doesn't this just fuel people's
conspiracy theories
yeah for sure the moment you start
censoring speech people automatically
think why am I not being allowed to hear
this I want to see this I want to read
it for myself and so you get What's
called the Streisand Effect a backfire
effect where you know the attempt to
censor it this comes from Barbra
Streisand suing to have a photograph of
her house in Malibu taken from a boat uh
censored taken off this web page and I
think at the time she filed the suit up
maybe 12 people had seen this picture of
her house after she filed a lawsuit it
was like downloaded 400 000 times in a
week right so now be careful about what
you call attention to we don't want you
to see this oh okay in that case I want
to see it and you know so I'm a pretty
strong Free Speech fundamentalist you
know just let everybody have their say
you know let Trump back on social media
I want to know what he's thinking you
know I'm not a trump fan to say the
least but uh if he's influential and
he's tweeting it you know he's putting
stuff out to the public at three in the
morning I want to know what that is you
know just in case right so I don't want
some tech committee as we've seen in the
Twitter threads telling me what I can
and cannot see you know I know there's
exceptions you know should we let Isis
on there to recruit you know members to
become Terror no all right should we
allow the nuclear codes to be posted on
Twitter no right there's some obvious
ones like that but you know really how
harmful are are these kinds of uh people
that are on there and the hypocrisy
right so Barry Weiss posted that one of
you know the the decisions to kick Trump
off uh Twitter was pretty questionable
right they went back and forth for days
and finally decided to kick him off in
the meantime you have uh you know these
people in Iran posting things about uh
uh Israel oh well you know we should
just take Israel right off the map
because of the Jews and that gets posted
and no one says hey oh maybe that should
be censored so it I think when people
see that hypocrisy they think you know
this this is not right
look Michael I agree with you broadly
however there are more complex cases in
the ones that you've just cited what
about Alex Jones for instance doesn't
Alex Jones deserve a platform but he's
about his conspiracy theories as in the
case of Sandy Hook which are very real
very dangerous and people could have
been killed
yeah I'm a little conflicted about that
I'm not a Alex Jones fan to say the
least and I've spent years debunking him
um why is he responsible for what his
lunatic wackadoodle followers do why
aren't they responsible I only know of
one case of a woman who actually went
into somebody's house or was on their
lawn or something who was convicted for
uh harassing somebody at their home the
other uh family members were harassed by
these people I guess they were out on
the public street so it's harder to you
know to to file charges against them for
harassment if you're you know on a
public ground something like that but it
brings up the larger subject of to what
extent does somebody's words make
somebody do something that they would
not otherwise have done like Trump's
speech on January 6 that morning uh I'm
told by First Amendment attorneys that
it's a very high bar to meet to connect
words to actions your words to somebody
else's actions and that you know uh and
that probably you could not convict
Trump for causing the January 6th
Insurrection
directly because of his words or just to
go back in time Manson Charlie Manson
telling his followers his cult followers
go to the Tate labianca homes and murder
those people uh Sharon Tate and so forth
and they did he wasn't even there uh and
he got convicted for first degree murder
by Vincent bouliosi and who famously
also got the the women convicted so it's
an interesting case of you know free
will to what extent are you unduly
influenced by somebody else it's a hard
a psychological problem to solve you
know that you made these people do this
I was just binge watching this Netflix
series called don't pick up the phone I
don't know if you remember these cases
but this was a a Prank Caller to a
McDonald's who got the manager to strip
search one of the young female employees
in the back office and the whole thing
is recorded on a CCTV video and this guy
is just a just some nobody at a pay
phone this is like in 1999 2000 time
frame
um who somehow managed to keep this
manager on the phone for three hours
strip searching this woman she's
completely naked she's doing jumping
jacks and jumping up and down naked so
that the money she allegedly stole would
fall out of her body parts or something
I mean it's just insane and how is it
that somebody could do that from a pay
phone you know and just say I'm a cop
and here's what you're gonna do and that
the listeners don't go hey hang on for a
second you want me to strip this woman
down and make her do jumping this is not
right and yet somehow this happened like
68 times in the course of a decade
um so to what extent are we truly free
or other people can make us do things so
that's kind of what you're getting at
there you know yeah should we hold Alex
Jones responsible maybe but again I
first of all he does have a platform you
know uh Kanye West and and uh the other
guy the the uh Nick Fuentes were just on
a show he still has a massive following
so he's not the government did not go in
and shut him down private platform said
we're not going to have you on anymore
would I have done that if I own Twitter
probably not you know it's like I want
to know what this lunatic is is thinking
and I tend to have more faith in in
people that they may be unduly confident
in people's rationality
um I know some people are more
influential than others Jones is
Apparently one of them but how's that
different from Rush Limbaugh rambling on
about you know or Sean Hannity or Tucker
Carlson or any of those rambling on
about you know the left the Liberals the
libtards you know and they go on and on
this every day for hours and people are
definitely influenced by that to the
extent that they just hate liberals they
hate Democrats you know they're they're
they're satanic evil people you know
it's it this is not the politics of all
why are Hannity and Carlson and Ingram
and The Rush Limbaugh radio people of
the world why are they not being
censored or kicked off platforms for
their undue influence on people but
Michael shorty isn't on these platforms
on George
like if you remember during the very
start of the pandemic David Ike uh the
some would say the original and the best
uh you copied this yeah you know he was
doing these interviews about you know
curve 5G causing covid
and it was been it was put it was being
or it was platformed on YouTube it was
watched by millions of people and that
creates a very real problem and it
creates a real very real problem for
YouTube for example where people are
saying to them how can you being be how
are you allowing this to be broadcast on
your platform surely they're in an
untenable position they have to get rid
of him
maybe yes uh I mean I know David Ike uh
I don't know him personally but I've
been following him for 25 years I mean
he's been he's been doing this for a
long time I guess he's more influential
now I suppose because of social media
YouTube and so on
um what to do about it you know again
this is slightly different than it used
to be because you know the New York
Times is not going to interview him
every day uh or the Wall Street Journal
or NBC CBS uh uh ABC and so on uh
YouTube is a different you know social
media platforms again you know you know
this debate you know to what extent are
they just uh uh like the Public Square
you know this is just a public space
anybody could go there like Hyde Park in
London just go there with your bullhorn
and say whatever you want and people can
listen to you or not and is it more like
that so as you know there's you know
there's probably going to be some
lawsuits and major Congressional debates
about whether these companies should be
broken up or more regulated because of
that uh they're claiming we're just like
the phone company so if I'm on the phone
with you and I and I libel you you can't
sue at T my phone company or is it
Sprint I forget what my phone company is
but you know they're just a platform for
us to talk and you know it's YouTube and
and Twitter more like that or are they
more like the New York Times it should
be held accountable and the problem is
you know the New York Times gets let's
say maybe a hundred op-ed submissions a
day they publish one or two they're
vetted fact checked the editors stand up
for it and so on uh and they can be held
accountable for that if somebody liable
somebody else and harms them and there's
damages because of this New York Times
article about them but what if they got
submitted and published I don't know a
hundred thousand op-eds a day how can
they possibly control that fact check
and regulate they can't and so that what
do you do about Facebook that you know
or or Twitter where you you get
something like a hundred thousand posts
whatever it is a minute or an hour
something just it's a massive number I
don't know what to do about that it just
seems an intractable problem
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country we judge
Men's Health by his ability to wrestle
bear turns out in London Russell bear
has very different meaning
let's go out of hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my ancestors well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 a simple and easy way to get
all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we use it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day 81 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we had hugely successful trip it is very
economical and I felt strong enough to
wrestle American birth which we all know
is grotesly weak compared to great
rationberg if you're looking for a
simpler and cost effective supplement
routine 81 is giving you a free one year
supply of vitamin D and five travel
packs with your first purchase this go
into athletic greens.com
trigonometry that's athletic greens.com
trigonometry check it out and become
real men like me
Michael you mentioned the social media
companies and Twitter and particularly
is an interesting one because of the
Twitter files information drops we've
had over the last couple of weeks uh and
uh it's interesting to watch the
different sides of the political
Spectrum you know Francis and I are
somewhere in the center so we just sit
back and watch it unfold and I look at
the right uh so to speak if there is
such a thing and the writer is like this
is a massive conspiracy and on this
particular issue I actually uh I lean
towards not so much a conspiracy but
these people were doing things they
shouldn't have been doing they were
lying about what they were doing that's
my opinion uh and they while the
decisions as you rightly say are very
difficult uh they did not quite live up
to the standards that they claimed to be
upholding in my opinion on the other
hand the left is like well we knew this
was going on there's no problem this is
all just you know Elon trying to trying
to smear people and and attack people
that he's fired and whatever where do
you come down is the Twitter files a big
release reveal or is it a damn squib
yeah so I I have read it
um I was not surprised because I think
we all knew that Twitter was pretty far
left-leaning so on one hand it would be
like saying uh you know maybe I don't
know Peter Thiel buys no let's use
another example George Soros buys Fox
News and says oh my God I can't believe
it there's been a right-leaning slant in
favor of Republicans for all these years
can you believe it everybody would be
like what are you crazy everybody knows
that you can't watch it for five minutes
and not realize it's a total
right-leaning GOP uh there's a
difference so no one's been gaslighting
the public for years claiming Fox News
is a left of center publication with
Twitter the argument was oh no we're not
Shadow Banning anyone except they were
oh no the decision to ban Donald Trump
wasn't made because of personal
animosity yet we find out that your Roth
one of the major Executives had said the
the Nazis were in the White House three
years earlier so the the we were being
told one thing and then we find out
actually yes I agree with you I was not
surprised to find out that what Twitter
had been saying for years was a lie
however they were saying it wasn't a lie
and now we know and have evidence that
it was a lie I think that's quite
significant don't you yeah yeah so to be
fair Fox News did drop its fair and
balanced line that it used to use and
pretending to be neutrals they've given
that up if Twitter did that if they just
said publicly years ago you know what we
you know we're a left-leaning liberal
platform have at it that would be
acceptable because then everybody knows
so yeah I agree with you that the
the deception involved you know we are
politically neutral when the Twitter
threads so far show that they're not
politically neutral although again I
followed all those threads I've read
them all it you know it's they're little
Snippets it would be it would be nice to
see those documents in more context sure
you know like like a nice 10 000 word
investigative piece in the New Yorker
something like that that you get where
you see everything and you know who is
this guy again and how long have you
been there and how many documents were
there you know we get one document but
how many documents were there is this
one out of a hundred that's an anomaly
and the rest are pretty neutral or is
this a trend you know we just haven't
seen the larger context so at the moment
I think I agree with you that Twitter as
a Public Square where everybody can have
their say and is neutral was not the
case and so that would be a kind of
conspiracy back to to my definition
conspiracy two or more people plotting
secret to do something to a third party
or somebody else illegally or immorally
um that would be the case they they're
lies that you know we are a politically
neutral platform but secretly behind the
scenes they're Shadow Banning people and
so on that would be a conspiracy a
conspiracy theory that's that turned out
to be true it is a conspiracy and I
think the significance of it also was
Michael when you see how people reacted
around the world to Donald Trump being
banned I understand in America by you
know January the 6th or the 8th of 2021
there was quite a lot of people who who
were quite happy to see Donald Trump go
off every platform and they didn't
particularly care if it was right or
balanced or whatever and I do I don't
agree but I understand I understand
that's how heated the moment was but
when you see President macron Angela
Merkel uh Alexey navalny the opposition
leader in Russia these are not exactly
massive trumpists and Trump fans all
going whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you've
gone too far here you know I I thought
that was a really significant common and
you know seeing some insight yes Twitter
had their deliberations back and forth
but in the end they made a decision
which I just thought was catastrophic
and what we now know from the Twitter
files is that that decision was not made
on the basis of they he broke the rules
it was made on the basis of well we've
got to do something about this guy let's
make it up as we go along surely that's
got to be a concern yeah so you know one
of the reasons Barry Weiss said she left
the New York Times was because she was
just tired of she was working in the
opinion editorial Department you know
just do we need another you know the
967th op-ed piece against Donald Trump
you know so but but again I guess he
would say and you'd probably be right
the New York Times is clearly
left-leaning at least in their opinion
section that's the whole point just like
the Wall Street Journal if you want to
read a good skeptical Skeptics of
climate change read The Wall Street
Journal video they published Bjorn
Lombard pretty much every month where he
you know he pushes back against you know
the number of forest fires and the
number of tornadoes or you know the
greenhouse gases causing this or that
and but but you kind of know that ahead
of time right you you get the New York
Times because you like the left leaning
op-ed section or the Wall Street Journal
for the opposite uh but with Twitter
that's not the case again it's it's
probably a one-off special thing why
aren't there six twitters the equivalent
of that to compete with each other in a
free market wait why can't Peter teal
say start a new Twitter of course Elon
just bought that let's see what happens
but why aren't there you know three of
them yeah and it's an interesting
problem economically and and so the
natural monopolies Michael that's why
yes no one wants to use the fourth best
Twitter in the world I mean look at
Paula look at mastodon look at truth no
one wants to go in there left or right
because you want to be where everyone
else is at exactly yes yeah exactly
right so that's a problem and it's but
it's that's the case all over the I mean
how many search engines are there really
just Google I mean there's Bing and
Yahoo whatever everybody uses Google you
know how many diaper companies are there
two right I mean it's just how many
smartphone companies are there what
three I mean it's just it's just the way
it goes there's you know kind of a
market Head Start you end up with a a
Pareto distribution a power law where
you know 10 of the products you know
generate 90 of the revenue or you know
even worse or you know just Take podcast
platforms you know like two probably one
percent of the podcasters have 99 of the
audience it's just the way it goes I
guess it's up one percent that she uh
according to us Spotify
all right you are the one percenters
yeah we are whoa whoa whoa no no no
but Michael have people become most
conspiratorial because it seems that
there's a number of conspiracy theories
that have been proven correct for
instance uh a public conspiracy as you
know is you know there is this cabal of
pedophiles you know who operate at the
highest Echelon of society and we all
thought that was nonsense and then
you've got you know Jimmy Savile in our
country wanna you know consider
fraternizing with royalty Prince Charles
literally used to go to him and ask him
for advice
he his crimes were hushed up until he
died then you had Epstein and he was
obviously killed and there's a lot of
people out there with good reason who
think
you know he was killed let's put it
bluntly and then the only person who
went down for his crimes was just Lane
Maxwell or Jalen sorry Maxwell and then
the black book where everybody else who
did the Unspeakable Deeds was suppressed
well okay let me give you my take on
that when Epstein died and there were
conspiracy theories about that he was
killed I thought nah that's probably not
the case and then then they had the CCTV
video well the camera went out I went
okay that's a little fishy and then the
story came out about the second camera
was out of like okay that's that sounds
pretty iffy you know if you hear a knock
on the door you think oh what was that
if you hear you're like ah that sounds
like a pattern if you heard one two
three it'd be somebody's at the door
right so that seems suspicious to me I
posted on Twitter you know yeah I think
there's something to the conspiracy
theory and then somebody wrote me
emailed me from that prison that said I
used to work at that prison and nothing
works there it's a dump I thought okay
so this is the conspiracy principle
don't attribute to malice what can be
explained by incompetence or chance so
I'm back to thinking he probably just
killed himself because he had nothing
left to you know he just hit the hit the
wall there was nothing more he could do
is leading a miserable life and he's
probably not going to ever be freed so
um and so he probably took his own life
the rest of your narrative is rational I
mean he surely has a black book or I
guess Colleen Maxwell has a black why
isn't she although I would ask why isn't
she leveraging the black book to get out
or get a lighter sentence because she
doesn't want to kill herself Michael
that's why
I mean if I if I was her you know
because most of these cases uh like this
are plea bargained early on like okay
listen I know you but you're about to
put me on trial I'm probably doomed I
got the black book I'll I'll name names
if you you know let me go or let me free
after five years or whatever something
like that she didn't do that is is kind
of suspicious
um it's a little bit like the theory
you're working for our side here
whatever you say no
Francis said
well okay but in reality back okay Jimmy
Savile Epstein these you know these
things happen at a time when you know
way before uh the metoo movement and so
on and the awareness of pedophilia where
you know I followed the Jimmy civil I
watched that there was a I think a
Netflix or HBO yeah it was a Netflix
documentary that Netflix series yeah it
was pretty interesting I think
in hindsight this idea well they should
have known look at all the clues it's
like yeah but you have the curse of
knowledge you already know what happened
so it's obvious when he jokes about
children or he makes this little line
about young girls or whatever it's like
ah see right there he's admitting it but
but only after the fact when you already
know he's a pedophile
when it's not clear when you don't know
and you think huh that was kind of weird
well he's a weird guy he is he was a
weird guy and he was kind of quirky yeah
yeah but I think a lot of this kind of
hand ringing after the fact
um you know no but the point is
something else Michael which I think
Francis is correct about which is if you
believe uh in the conspiracy theory that
the world is run by a cabala pedophiles
and I happen to not believe that even
though the the things that Francis said
I actually agree with I think they're
true the thing with Jimmy Savile was he
was celebrated and we have clear
evidence that he would it's not like he
committed these crimes on his own and
nobody knew it's that lots and lots of
people protected him and lots and lots
of people turned the Blind Eye and he
was extremely well connected in the
highest echelons of society so people
knew what he was doing and they allowed
him to get away with it because he was
powerful and so from that I don't think
it's much of a believe to conclude that
there are probably other pedophiles in
the Epstein case shows that there are
people who would go and do these things
who work together who protect each other
who are very wealthy and to this day to
do not get Justice right now surely you
take all those inputs I I wouldn't blame
someone from concluding out of all of
that the world is run by a
cabalapedophiles
well that's how the conspiracy theory uh
starts the pizzagate one for example
that there's a secret satanic cult of
pedophiles operating out of the Comet
Ping Pong Pizzeria run by Hillary
Clinton you know do people really
believe that do they really believe that
one guy
I'll get to let me let me address that
sure sorry direct so one guy did Edgar
Welch he went there with his gun which
is what you would do if you really
thought there was a crime being
committed no one was doing anything
about it so here is what I call proxy
conspiracism or tribal conspiracy I
think when when
significant percentages of Republicans
say yeah they think there might be
something to the pizza gate the Q Anon
the whole pedophile thing do they really
believe that or are they just kind of
ticking off the box to pollsters yeah
that's what our tribe believes are yeah
it's a it's a proxy for something else I
don't like the clintons I hate Hillary I
don't I want to own the libtards I don't
like Democrats you know and so even if I
took you to the comment ping pong
Pizzeria and go look there's no pet
there's no there's no basement there's
no pedophile ring here you know it's not
like you're gonna go oh in that case
I'll vote for Hillary you know you were
never going to vote for Hillary right so
it's a stand it's a proxy I don't like
this group over here people are saying
they're doing these things yeah maybe
there's something to it even if there is
in that case there's kind of a more
General negative valence to your
opinions about them okay so to
um the Epstein case but let's let's just
take I think you're correct I think
there's a lot of people that are
involved or aided uh say uh take
something like um not Epstein um the
other the other movie Mogul uh Harvey
Weinstein you know it was clear his Mo
was that he would get
um these actresses to come up to his uh
hotel room for a late night meeting
right and so it's one thing to think
well they're a little naive to go to a
hotel room you know by themselves with
Jeffrey Epstein late at night and not
think there was something going to
happen sexually but they didn't go up
there by themselves they were brought up
there by women who worked for
um Weinstein like his assistant director
whoever they're the whatever their job
titles were and they would go well
Harvey wants to have a meeting with you
and they would actually get in the
elevator and go up to the room with
these women so
why have they not been
convicted or tried or even charged with
something like aiding and abating a
crime that that that's a thing right so
and I have no idea why that's but
clearly that was part of this kind of
psychological
um kind of prepping for getting somebody
to let their guard down you know the
kind of the gift of fear is it's called
you know women have an instinct about
not trusting men uh about possible
sexual abuse but if you have a woman in
the elevator with you going oh I'm going
to take you up to Harvey's room and
we're going to have this meeting you're
thinking well I guess she's going to be
here if she's indicating it's okay it
must be okay and then as we know now
that these women would then just quietly
leave the room they must have known
these these women helping him they must
have known he was up to something you
know late at night in a hotel room with
these young women actresses how could
they not it's a two-year point so why is
you know why is nobody that that
assisted um uh Jimmy Savile why why are
they not being charged with something
the answer is I don't know
but if you kind of make you know
but Michael if you take the Epstein
point erlane
she's gone down for a crimes good
everybody's happy about that
the fact but she was the conduit between
the young girls
Epstein and all the other men
and we know the other men because there
was a flight log but you were saying
that he was the only guy and all these
rich and Powerful guys
it just doesn't ring true and to me it
just fuels conspiracy theories around
this because we know as a society as a
as a people we're not being told the
truth
and that to me is what really hilarious
allows the conspiracy theories to
flourish this is I tracked the kind of
the origins of the pizza gate conspiracy
theory in my book that it was kind of an
overlapping of several threads again you
know just owning The libtards Hating the
Democrats and so on and then you know
all this the stuff about the clintons in
the 90s and their uh you know that they
had people murdered and so on and then
Bill Clinton's uh you know uh
preference for young uh women but adult
women and then you have the Epstein
thing with you know all these people on
the Jets and Epstein's preference
appeared to be young women well
teenagers right 13 say age 14 15 to 17.
that seemed to be his window of of
sexual preference and so but that's an
underage uh a young teenage woman girl
and technically that's pedophilia so you
get this well there was a pedophile ring
going on on that jet on that island with
Democrats like Bill Clinton and whoever
else is on that list on that plane and
so it seems like okay you kind of put it
all together and you just use the word
pedophile which is technically correct
for for Epstein but it isn't like he's
having sex with five-year-olds right
these are teenage girls but in people's
minds you kind of throw all that
together and you end up with the
pizzagate thing and that you know and
then the Q Anon drops you know cheese
pizza CP with child pornography and you
know just and then the and then the
thing just takes off that's a conspiracy
theory that's not true technically
there's no pedophile ring at this
Pizzeria but it has elements to it oh
and the one other thing of the drinking
of the blood you know that there was the
stories about these Tech billionaires
who wanted to have the blood
transfusions from young children to get
that adrenal hormone that supposedly
leads to anti-aging and things like that
so you throw that in the mix right and
those Tech billionaires tend to be
liberals you know industrial rich people
lean right and tech people rich people
lean left so something there you kind of
throw all that together and you get
literacy theory that technically isn't
true but the little elements of it are
true and then that's what happens in
people's minds
yeah I think the problem is Michael
where the case like Epstein it was so
shocking and there was so many like
high-profile people and like I said
before that there's a complete lack of
transparency which just means that like
you've talked about you know the pizza
game whatever else and of course those
ones are complete nonsense but this
feels something like something far more
Sinister and formal real and true to
life
right okay so again back to my
constructive conspiracism people are
naturally suspicious and think there's
something going on because often there
is so there's back to pedophilia there
are pedophiles this really does happen
it really is a crime and you know what
the numbers are are debatable you know
whether it's you know one percent two
percent six percent ten percent uh of
children are abused um it's it's
debatable but it's not zero and so like
back in the 90s we tracked a movement
called the recovered memory movement
which was these are adult mostly women
in therapy for various reasons and being
told by these therapists well you know
perhaps you were
um oops lost you guys now keep going
okay keep going uh so back in the 90s
there was this recovered memory movement
which these mostly adult women in
therapy were uh told by the therapist
that maybe your problem stems from being
molested as a child and they were going
well I don't think I was I don't have
any memory that oh it's a repressed
memory you repressed it because it's so
traumatic and now we can help you
recover that memory of being molested
and this went on and on for years and
there were there were men these are
fathers grandfathers uncles family
friends and so on who were uh charged
tried convicted and jailed for molesting
uh children based on only one of these
recovered memories they used hypnosis or
just guided imagery or whatever in these
therapy sessions and it turned out to be
complete bunk this was totally uh
stopped by lawsuits against these
therapists for planting false memories
and the problem at the time though was
that pedophilia is not zero it's a real
thing right so it was hard to tell how
do you know if somebody was molested as
a child Well it can't just be based on a
recovered memory you have to have some
testimony from other family members who
witnessed it or participated or saw it
happening or whatever and so again this
is the kind of problem we face now you
know to what extent uh
should we be looking for this so here I
would say that you know conspiracy
theories about pedophilia or sexual
assault you know should be taken
seriously they might be true just in
case but but you have to look at the
evidence for each conspiracy theory in
particular and then and then break it
down from there Michael one of the
things that I think uh has happened
particularly in recent years and I do
connected to the pandemic is I think a
lot of people uh have been persuaded
that
uh there is an agenda to take more power
away from Ordinary People and to
accumulate it in the hands of a few the
WF the great reset uh and all of that
and uh as someone who likes the
occasional spliff I've stayed away from
it just because during the pandemic I I
was tempted to sort of believe all that
stuff so I'm like let's not look at it
because I might believe it because right
now it seems quite credible
um but a lot of people are talking about
we were actually going to be talking to
Michael schellenberger who's written
about this and he's a guy I really
respect I think he he's a great
journalist and he's written about it and
he says that there are elements of it
which are true and there's a book and
and the website and blah blah blah I
mean I looked on the website didn't seem
uh Uber suspicious to me but a lot of
people are persuaded by all of this
stuff first of all uh what do you make
of all the stuff about Klaus Schwab I
mean Cloud Schwab doesn't help himself
the way he speaks and looks it's not he
looks like a stereotypical villain
um uh what do you make of the W that's
the great reset and all of that you mean
the uh like mask mandates and things
like that as a way of controlling people
setting up the population to control
them to get them to conform in other
ways as well I think that's part of what
some people roll it into but I think the
central argument as I understand that is
uh the world economic Forum gets
together and tries to influence
politicians and other decision makers uh
who have authority and power to end the
system of capitalism that we have now uh
in order to get a central government in
place that controls the entire world and
and these people are doing them because
they want to you know stop climate
change and change the economic model so
that quote unquote you own nothing and
you'll be happy that that yeah okay uh
well here first of all is that a
conspiracy theory a lot of these people
just take a Greta thurnberg type person
you know there's no secret about what
she believes right or the Bernie Sanders
of the world or you know the Socialists
or whoever they they're open about it
like yeah we should end capitalism you
know it's all the kind of antifa people
you know we should destroy the entire
system colonialism capitalism white you
know all the white way of thinking and
so on that's not a conspiracy because
they're pretty open about it now are
there people that meet in secret to do
things yes but the more specific
the target the more likely that
conspiracy theory is to be true right so
like control you know world domination
taking over the world you know that's a
pretty hard thing to do that's a big ask
uh people meet in in secrecy to
influence specific things my example
Volkswagen cheating the emission
standards and yeah of the EU in order to
make more money well we know
corporations do things like that insider
trading and stuff like that you know
when these uh Disney Executives you know
play golf with politicians you know of
course they're chatting up in between
the holes you know what what policy
might be uh passed to influence their
corporate standing you know the whole
Ron DeSantis thing about calling
attention to Disney in Florida uh
because of their woke policy that he
didn't like but in fact it was kind of
revealing that they got all these tax
breaks they didn't have to do the things
that other corporations have to do it's
like oh yeah well that doesn't seem very
free market capitalism either but of
course we know Disney set this up back
in the 60 and 70s by giving money to
politicians and things like that so but
again it's the more specific the Target
have he looked into the gray reset I
guess is what I'm getting there uh not
really let's let's talk about that give
me the give me well I I I haven't looked
into that much A lot of people keep
talking about it so what I'd love to do
is if you get a chance to have a look at
it uh let me know what you think about
it because I think a lot of people will
be curious well again if if by this you
mean this you know we're going to reset
the entire economic political system of
the world first of all that's not gonna
happen
um and second the people that are open
about it that's not a conspiracy you
know there are a lot of marxists and
anti-capitalists around
um not a majority and they're probably
not going to get elected do anything
about it but they're out there and
certainly they try to influence people
like academics you know are very far
left-leaning and are are super critical
of capitalism uh but that's that's a
little bit different than there's a
secret group cabal the Illuminati or
whoever you know the world economic
forum and Davos and so on you know they
their targets are very specific this is
what we want to do
in order to gain some Advantage for our
group or our tribe our nation our
Corporation whatever yes that happens
but I would be skeptical of a conspiracy
theory that said you know they're
meeting to take over the world or
something like that because that just
doesn't happen I mean they may be but
you know is it is it are they really
going to do it you know probably not and
is it just a a small Fringe group of
nuts you know or just extremists because
you can find those in any country
now you can find somebody to say you
know you have a population of 340
million Americans you can find somebody
to say almost anything that's completely
crazy did they represent some large
percentage of the population probably
not and the thing about Trump was that
uh his he is in he's pretty extreme but
his influence was so Broad in the GOP
that it became a real issue is this the
new Republican party and now it's
looking like it's probably not going to
go that direction that they were
speaking here but we'll see
Michael and let's move on to people who
believe in conspiracy theories like you
always hear oh there's this they're just
a weed smoke and conspiracy theorist in
his basement tends to be male tends to
be like I said smoking weed someone who
you know doesn't really interact with
Society with societies on the internet
enough about us 16 hours a day
well I mean that summed up pretty much
everyone during the pandemic but
um is that true or is is that a misnomer
no it's a complete misnomer I debunked
that in the first chapter of the book uh
there's tons of evidence now there's a
lot of uh social scientists who
researched this lots of polling data and
and so forth um Everybody believes at
least one conspiracy theory and again
back to my constructive conspiracism and
my argument is that it's rational to
believe conspiracy theories because
enough of them are true it pays to err
on the side of caution just in case as
they say just because you're paranoid
doesn't mean they're not after you
sometimes they are after you right so we
know from uh lots of surveys that people
that believe various conspiracy theories
even a lot of them are not these
wackadoodle tinfoil hat wearing people
living in their parents basement they
are regular people we know the Q Anon
has been followed by a lot of people
that have careers jobs marriages
families children they keep gas of the
tank money in the bank they take their
kids to school every morning they go to
work they have a career job so on and
then they show up on January 6th you
know to take over the U.S government
like what
uh you know why because they really
believed it and because the boss told
him so and you know so they again but
those people we now know who all of them
were pretty much everybody who was there
these are normal people and you know if
you look at any of the major conspiracy
theories and who Embraces it most of it
is just regular people so one of the
things I'm trying to do in the book is
is to dispel the myth of that conspiracy
theory should be a pejorative oh that's
just a crazy conspiracy theory that's
that's a post-world War II uh phenomenon
and there's theories about that that the
CIA planted this idea or the FBI after
the JFK assassination let's make
conspiracy theories to sound like a
crazy thing so we can you know cover our
tracks of the conspiracy theory that JFK
was assassinated by the CIA or whoever
um so there's some debates about that
but whatever the cause of that before
World War II the idea of conspiracy
theories was completely normal
you know people like Churchill and
Roosevelt leaders of the Free World and
so on all Embrace conspiracy theories
again the Catholics are doing this the
Jews are doing that the Mormons are
influencing our elections and so on that
was pretty normal part of the regular
conversation not a pejorative at all so
I'm trying to get back to that because
again if you just go through some of the
conspiracies I cover in the book you
know the CIA MK Ultra program of dosing
American citizens without their
knowledge or consent with psychoactive
drugs what you know our operation paper
clip where we're hiring these Nazi
scientists to build weapons of mass
destruction for us while some of their
colleagues are being put on in the
docket at Nuremberg and executed for war
crimes doing the same thing right or the
project cointel Pro the
counterintelligence program by the FBI
to infiltrate
um civil rights groups like the Black
Panthers and the American Indian
movement in feminist groups and so on
with plants to make them look bad to do
stupid things to do illegal things so
that they could be busted by the FBI all
the way up to the point of of tape
recording Martin Luther King Jr's
sexcapades and hotel rooms and then
blackmailing him with a letter we have
the letter it signed off by J Andrew
Hoover himself the head of the FBI you
know that if you don't kill yourself or
take yourself out of the Civil Rights
Movement we're going to expose your your
these tapes to the public and it's
astonishing the things that our
government is Cia assassinations of
foreign leaders this was a thing for
decades you know the attempts to kill
Castro are you know famous right dozens
of attempts to kill Castro and Che
Guevara the CIA assassinated him in
Bolivia in 1968. that was a that was our
government so you know when we rail
about Putin having people assassinated
yeah that's bad that you know but our
government has done things like that so
when people say you know what I don't
really trust the US government I don't
trust voucher I don't trust the CDC I
don't trust the CIA the FBI I say I
understand there's good reasons why you
shouldn't
all right Michael you've made a
conspiracy theorist out of me there uh
but I was curious
um uh is there any research which
indicates who or why isn't people are
interested in conspiracy what kind of
person what is it that makes somebody
more credulous of them than than not and
uh what is it about believing in them
that people like or want or need or
whatever sure there's a lot of research
I I summarize in the book of uh you know
like Race For example is a predictor of
what kind of conspiracy theory you
Embrace white Americans are more likely
to think the US government is conspiring
to take away our guns Black Americans
are more likely to think that the
government is conspiring to plant crack
cocaine in inner cities or or uh
invented aids to decimate black
populations and so on because of the
Tuskegee experiments uh men and women
are there's no difference on gender or
sex
yes let's not go there
uh but but so these kinds of things do
direct people's attention to certain
conspiracy theories they're more likely
to embrace but not General conspiracism
there's there's no one group that's more
paranoid than the other there are
individual variations in how say
openness high and openness to experience
means you're open to new ideas so you're
more likely to believe a lot of
conspiracy theories
um whether or not they're true uh
education attenuates conspiracism
somewhat it's about 40 percent of people
with a high school diploma Embrace
conspiracy theories about 20 of people
with postgraduate degrees Embrace
conspiracy theories so that's you know
that's a huge Improvement uh in in
rational thinking from college education
but that one in five Americans with
postgraduate degrees we're talking phds
MDS law degrees and so on believe
conspiracy theories a lot of them tells
us okay there's something else going on
here it's not just being smart and
rational educated
um can protect you from conspiracism and
again the reason I'm arguing is because
they it is rational to believe
conspiracy theories because enough of
them are true that we should be
suspicious of powerful groups rich
people you know it's like even Obama
who's you know Mr transparency very
smart educated rational I really liked
him and then you know he gets in there
and and all of a sudden you know the the
NSA program was ramped up Homeland
Security is ramped up we're surveilling
the American public not just metadata
but actually surveilling people's uh
calls and so on even tracking Angela
merkel's cell phone call our government
under Obama not just Bush but under
Obama you know he's going to close gitmo
didn't happen uh right I mean just just
think about that we have prisoners in in
Guantanamo Bay and Cuba uh that are not
protected by the the league the
Constitution or our legitimate legal
system they've been there 20 plus years
without a trial I mean what our
government's doing this so no wonder you
know that people are suspicious there's
something happens when people get into
power I don't know what it is it's like
all of a sudden you start thinking
differently and you know I think they
take you in the back room and they go
okay here's what's really going on in
the world
oh I was going to pull the troops out
yeah yeah no don't you're not doing that
yeah no I can't do that
yeah sorry I was going to ask if this
the thing
um I noticed that among people who
believe particularly these conspiracy
theories or you know whatever you want
to call them these ideas about uh I
think at the core of them there's a
certain
self-victumhood to them there is you
know we are the oppressed and the elites
this evil cabal of Elites have got
together to take away even more of our
rights and and they're going to take our
money and they're going to take our
houses and you can't have a hamburger
anymore and you can't drive a car and
and uh look maybe maybe they've got
legitimate concerns but it seems to me
when I talk to these people and I listen
to the way they talk and I hear the
stuff that they say I get the sense that
there's a part of them that actually
really enjoys this idea there's a sort
of there's a kind of emotional reward to
being this powerless person against whom
the world is conspired you have any
thoughts on that yeah so this is what's
known and conspiracy theory circles well
among Scholars who study conspiracy
theories called conspiracy theories are
for losers that is whoever loses an
election thinks the other side was up to
no good that some Shenanigans or fraud
or whatever every political party that's
lost an election thinks that for a while
what's different now is that you know
Trump kept it going even after he won in
2016 he still thought there was fraud
it's like what dude you won you're
supposed to stop talking about
conspiracy theories now it's the
Democrats that are supposed to be
talking about conspiracy theories and
they did but they did oh absolutely you
know Russian collusion and all that much
of which did not pan out like the
Democrats thought or in previous
elections you know when like in in Bush
both 2000 with the Florida hanging chad
uh issue with Al Gore and then in 2004
there were conspiracy theories from the
Democrats that bush there were some
Shenanigans I think in Ohio and Iowa or
uh it might have been one of the other
midwest states where there was
supposedly election fraud going on that
never panned out for the Democrats right
so it's not fair to say well Republicans
are more likely to be conspiratory no
Democrats are just as much Trump's his
own his own special case I think but
that's that's pretty normal we know that
people who whoever falls out of power
whoever does not have as much money
control Power thinks there's other like
in corporations people on the bottom are
more conspiratorial about the people at
the top people at top usually don't have
as much control and power as the people
in the bottom think that they do and
then just extrapolate that out to the
Jeff Bezos or Bill Gates or George Soros
of the world that Elon Musk now uh that
you know somehow there's something going
on there how'd they get that money it's
so much money it seems unfair and now
they're wielding all that influence well
they probably are to a certain extent
right and so it's reasonable it's
rational to be a little skeptical of
that
it's it's really interesting what we're
talking about and particularly because
the moment you've said about you know
the loser always believes as a
conspiracy theory I've been watching the
football rule as you call it incorrectly
the soccer World Cup and every loser
every losing team at least two or three
people have come out blamed the referee
and said the referee's buyer said the
referee is Bob
you know so I think it's just human
nature really that we we need to blame
someone for our own failings yeah
there's studies on this of showing uh
subjects videos of a football game or
whatever you know and and some of the
subjects are favor one team other
subjects would favor the other team and
they both see like the same foul or the
same incident that gets that the referee
calls on and the one side thinks of it
was a totally legitimate call and the
other side thinks oh it's the ref is
blind or he's biased or whatever it
happens every time that's totally
tribalism that's just tribal
conspiracism completely normal Michael
is there a correlation between drug
taking and conspiracy theories
[Music]
I have not seen any research on that but
I guess it would depend on the kind of
drugs well right if you talk about
openness to experience I imagine drugs
which increase your openness to new
experiences would increase your the
credit credulity for conspiracy theories
that wouldn't make sense wouldn't it I
wonder which ones uh would cannabis do
that certainly alcohol is a
disinhibitory drug so people are more
susceptible to well everything
um which is why you shouldn't make
decisions when you've been drinking
probably true for a lot of drugs I would
suspect yeah well Michael it's been a
fascinating chat uh thank you so much
for coming back as you know we're going
to ask you a couple of questions from
our local supporters that only they will
get to see but as always we've got one
final question for you which is what is
the one thing we're not talking about
that we really should be
oh well we conspiracism I think again is
an important topic more mainstream than
anyone I think realized I guess you're
going to talk about something else I I
really think this this whole Free Speech
issue is going to never end because it's
a hard problem to solve it's always open
I know you uh had our mutual friend Sam
Harrison your show and that erupted when
he he talked about censoring the hunter
Biden laptop I certainly disagree with
that uh you know put it all out there
and let everybody have their say but I
do understand there's an argument to be
made right when there's harm that's
going to be done and you know kind of in
a utilitarian way you do that calculus I
try to see it from the other person's
perspective I see where Sam's coming
from I disagree with it but I thought
the I thought the Heap of hate on his
shoulders was a little much uh for that
you know people have different positions
there are legitimate uh arguments to be
made on both sides you know you pick you
I pick one side openness to uh Free
Speech more than others maybe but you
know there's a argument to be made on
the other side anyway I just was going
to comment on that I enjoyed your show
with with Sam on that issue but it's an
open debate I think to what extent we we
should just open up the barriers and let
everybody have their say
well we invited Sam back on to talk
about why he left Twitter and so on but
he he didn't want to do it this time so
but we nonetheless you're right we we
certainly weren't happy with the fact
that he got so much hate and it's the
last thing we want for someone to come
on our show and then end up being
attacked in that way even if you know
whether we agree or disagree in this
case I think we're much more aligned
with with your way of thinking about it
anyway Michael the book is called uh
conspiracy where can people get it where
can people find uh
yeah so skipping.com uh is my website
and we have you can order autograph
books there or you can go to Amazon or
any bookstore carries it so yeah and
Michael shermer.com is my personal
website
um in my show Michael Schumer show it's
all you can find it all at skeptic.com
and I've been a guest on it so it must
be good
thanks so much for coming on and thank
you guys for watching and listening we
will see you very soon another brilliant
episode like this one oral show all of
them go out at 7 pm UK time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast
take care and see you soon guys
and is there anything any crazy
conspiracy theory that you did believe
that later turned out not to be true
[Music]